okay card on oh and Ferrari we've heard
of car down Oh who's heard of a lot of
eco Ferrari one person okay and they
really do deserve to be mentioned
together
this is Targa this is the book he
published in 1545 now as his vitals this
is the city of Milan he gained a
doctorate of medicine in 1526 I don't
know how when where he got into
mathematics officially but of course in
those days a lot of mathematics was done
by people whose principal elsewhere in
1536 he gained a student called what a
big a Ferrari now he was actually a
servant like a I think I don't know it
was just a domestic servant or a
clerical servant but he showed a lot of
mouse with with the clerics and I don't
know statistician knows and when card on
Oh
moved on from his university post so you
Taliban I was teaching mathematics at
University he arranged for for a Ferrari
to take his position then that was age
20 now they solved X cube plus a squared
cos equals B in 1539 so that was not
original italia was the first we know
off to do that but they rediscovered it
they could not they try no matter how
hard they try they could not crack the
depressed cubic and they knew it had
been done to I tell you boasted about it
okay he didn't keep it he kept the
method secret but he didn't keep his
knowledge Cedric he boasted about it so
but a couple of twists they learned the
solution Twice first one 15:39 they
learned from Italians they persuaded him
to to divulge it and he gave them the
result but not the method and Padano and
Ferrari wanted to publish it I don't
know what made them exempt from the
culture of competition maybe confidence
maybe not caring too much who knows but
they wanted to publish it they were
ready to publish they had the rest of
their book ready to publish at this time
and they wanted to include the cube but
that's hardly refused saying he was
going to publish it himself he just
wouldn't commit to when he was working
on other things and when I finished
those etc etc so they didn't they did
publish a book in 1539 but it didn't
include information on Cuba in 1543 well
what happened in the meantime is they
solved the general meaning that they
found the link between the general cubic
and the depressed cubic so they that
knowledge was original to them but they
couldn't really publish it because they
couldn't provide a proof if you like for
the depressed cubic they couldn't
provide a complete solution they were
getting desperate to publish guess what
else happened
Ferrari Salford 40 at about the same
time I haven't seen the mathematics
involved in that I don't almost don't
want to know but it was about the same
time maybe it's surprisingly simple and
so with this knowledge building they
were desperate to publish and so what
happened in 1543 they sought out della
Navi the son-in-law and they asked him
for information on the depressed cubic
and della Nova was not involved in
mathematics didn't have anything to go
too high he showed them Dell Pharaohs
notebooks so they learned the full
solution that the press pubic and
therefore the full solution of the cubic
. in 1543 and they considered and i
agree with them that that released them
from their obligation to tar talia not
to publish all right they found that
that knowledge predated Tattaglia they
have now come into that knowledge we
have yeah the son-in-law is permission
to publish we're publishing so in 1545
us magna was published monumental book
the sources I've read say that in a very
small timeframe at Copernicus published
his work some other important person
published their work and and this was
published in a very short timeframe and
I can only find one or two comments that
mentioned this but he was considered the
world's leading mathematician at this
time the course of this book and I guess
it does stand out that someone would
publish a book giving away lots of
knowledge in that culture bombelli
haven't mention him at all yeah i should
mention something actually about
this is about cubic equations and
complex numbers we've seen how how cubic
equations led to the concept of the
square root of a negative number in an
unavoidable way I was talking to someone
last night who echoed what everyone
would think that complex numbers came
into being because we wanted to solve
quadratics it's the most logical thing
to think in the world isn't but it's
false because there's an element of
choice there all right to solve
quadratics to invent complex numbers in
order to solve quadratics you have to
make a choice that you care about
solving all quadratics and their choice
was we don't care about solving all
quadratics were only interested in
really two solution of practical
problems or maths competition type
problems they are always going to have
positive solutions so yeah but they
there was no need to make that choice
but with cubic equations it was
unavoidable to get that solution of x
equals 4 you had to have you know 2 plus
this I plus 2 minus that pie right they
didn't use the number I they just used
the you know the square root of a
negative number at a time when they
weren't even using negative numbers so
kadhai know fifties Toth in that water
I think del Ferro avoided it altogether
I'd like to know more about that it's
easy to count what X cubed minus 15 x
equals 4 has the obvious solution x
equals 4 around 64 minus 16 equals 4 but
to get it that way you need to go by a
complex numbers well what was what did
he say about that there just seems so
little actual biographical information
Delf era compared to Cardona I guess
that's what publishing a book does right
and so I think del Ferro kind of avoided
that but I don't know how we could have
avoided it all together Cardona and
Ferrari whatever I say card on I'll make
it out on forever
Gennaro and Ferrari did their toe in it
Dave impressively I guess they were
inspired by these complex cubic things
to do know what to do with this square
root of negative numbers in them but it
perhaps inspired them to think of a
simpler example which is a good thing to
do when you're faced with something hard
isn't it so they in ask magna they
detail the problem find two numbers that
add to 10 and not apply to 40 and that
doesn't have any real number solution
but they found that five plus or minus
the square root of 59 ought to do it
sorry the square root of negative 15 so
5 plus or minus the square root of
negative 15 will do it for you and yeah
they they said Bravo this solves that
problem so they didn't have any they
didn't grow up learning complex numbers
they they didn't have any culture of
doing it and they they didn't seek to
implement them either it was just a case
of okay so we've got these problems
where these square roots of negative
numbers pop up what what do you do with
those so the the key phrase that I that
I like is I forget the exact words but
yeah nevertheless we shall proceed all
right so I've got these things I don't
know what to do with but you know if I
just try to apply normal rules of
calculation then I'll get someone that's
still a long way from because we need to
get the square root of negative 111 over
98 or something like I'd have chocolate
on pen paper I'd have trouble getting
the solution to the
so I heard on Oh didn't didn't go very
far down that path so he's he's widely
credited as being like the father of
complex numbers but that's kind of false
his achievements of wonderful he was a
pioneer of probability as well